16 year old boy remanded in custody
after appearing in court charged with
the murder of jody chesney in east
london
one of 39 people killed following
stabbings in britain since the beginning
of the year
just this month three 17 year olds were
killed in london
and in birmingham three teenagers died
in the space of 12 days
in february well as politicians and
police grapple with how to deal with the
surge in violence one man in london
has come up with his own solution and it
involves exchanging knives
for vouchers 99 crime campaigner farron
alex paul
is uh joining us now hello hi i saw you
on the telly this morning
you've got very interesting views on how
we can tackle knife crime tell me
um i just feel like you know it's just
i think the talking the time for talking
is kind of past it past now
and i just thought of something that how
i could interact with someone i just put
myself in that age
in that environment at that time and i
just thought ways of how can
help tell me so i just thought to myself
these young children
they haven't got income they go to
school they work they're in a lot of
arguments and confrontations in the
street and what does that leave someone
i mean
you're stuck in your mom's house of a
postcard you can't move
you don't work so the altercations
you're involved with you can never
escape
it so i just thought to myself if i can
find some sort of way
to let them willingly give their nurse
over then that in itself
is a positive transition and then on top
of that from there i've also thought of
a way where
all right if finances is your problem
i've now just started to
build something where they can basically
do online trading
and um dan roman wrote they've um
basically i'm speaking to someone and
we're going to take the market stores
over
where these young children better buy
products of their own as long as they're
legit
bring it down and sell it make your
profit and hopefully doing that they'd
be having
income of finances which they won't have
to go look for in a bad way
and they'd be away from the area where
they're having problems okay let's let's
take that one step at a time when you
say you're giving kids vouchers
in order to hand in their go are you
actually the knife are you
paying them to have knives no i'm not
paying them i'm paying them to not have
a knife
yeah but they've got to have if you and
then okay you've got another knife and
then
oh that's so basic um yeah so
and with kitcheness um i'll take it and
dispose it for you but i won't pay for
it because
i do not want every mother in england
message me like it's your fault that
i've lost all my kitchen out in the
drawer
so um i mean designing that's in it like
i mean our children are not blacksmiths
they're not sitting down in the shed
making you design a nerfs
and obviously if you got design enough
you probably paid for them so hey
here's your money you pay for them but
but in a voucher so you can't go and buy
guns
i mean so you can't go buy other weapons
or drugs of it i just basically evaded
myself from cruises a minute
how do you pay how do you get the money
to pay for these things
i've talked 30 knives away and each one
like
i give that 10 pound vouchers for knife
and 20 pound for the things
but half of the people hate they're not
taking vouchers some of them you know
what i mean so i've spent 300 pound take
next to me and and you're funding all
that yourself yeah a lot i just walk
into jd sports i say you can have a 20
voucher but i just buy loads of 10-pound
vouchers it's easier for me to
split up do you know what i mean and i
was just writing that i just write in a
voucher
to question mark from faz amnesty and
the price of the voucher and i'll just
be like keep winning keep changing like
it's little motivations like that
they go in there you buy your change 120
pounds cool just put
your vacuum and then now you pay 100
pounds 320. i don't know
and what response have you had you said
i've had a bigger response and what i've
done like i've just
got to the stage where i'm saying you
know what the 20 pound on my so
any voucher that's out there if you
really want it just ask for it and i'll
get a few
whether it's jd sports football car hmv
argos
right you can have it we've seen a
picture of you with a with a samurai
sword talk
talk to me about the background to this
oh this the samurai sword
oh i've had it up here which one up
there on the telly
you were handing it in apparently oh
there you are with it
can you see it wait there what video is
that oh wait there that's the van
what's my van i don't have rust now
oh this is our filming that we did with
you on friday remember
oh sorry that's david that's my g i
listen yeah
so basically i've gone down to southwest
london sorry about that but anyway
i've gone down there and i've met
someone and
what's happened yeah it was really crazy
but this i know that the trust is coming
now yeah
imagine this year so we've got down
there now as i've got down there
a big police fans come down the road
with the blue letters i'm like whoop
i've looked at one of the um sky guys
i'm like have you set me up like why
have you done this to me he's like no
no no no no i'm like whoop as he said
that to me here
the guy is the guy whoever i meet and he
can see me in it because he's around the
area somewhere he's like mate i just saw
police come down the road
i'm like bro trust me yeah it's not me
in it yeah but at the same time i've got
two camera crews in me i've got sky with
me i've got my personal camera crew
we've got three vans yeah
so it's a lot going on i don't know i'm
not our christ said we're never going to
get a dude and now we
then he's like he said two minutes but
the two minutes kind of went to five to
ten so i started pacing a bit
and i think that everyone is kind of
like because we're in the moment out of
this police fly in there this that the
guy upstairs coming down in the sunrise
so
she i'm just thinking ah mates i'm
texting like please don't let me come up
here
and but i don't know maria area i've
never been out there before i'm from
north london
that actually i mean i'm like please
don't let me come over here and and
and you film here then after i see and
kind of says i was like
yes and obviously i just want to handle
my business like you've got a thing for
me i've got it
once i got it my aim was to make it safe
i just got it i'm
out boom dave chat to him david started
talking to him and then
i don't know what it said there because
i just kept it moving yeah right on to
the sword
because what happened yeah if i just
stood there the sword for the interview
here and the police would have rolled up
here
then what they did in a lot of trouble
um
and i'd never say to guys i'd be like
cool it's mine and then that'd been
drama for me
but because it was in a protective
casing yeah and i got into the van
and then it's in the toolbox it's now
not in public property you understand
and then based i got it there so i just
said to myself mate google the nearest
police station
bang was there and that is it just kept
it moving um
you've been stabbed yourself aren't you
yeah what happened
oh listen i was defending my girlfriend
one time i got stabbed nine times i
defended my sister one time i got
stabbed nine times
and that is it it's never been a gang
thing
and you know what yeah that's my sister
in it that's my girlfriend
like my daughter my daughter or my mom
like coming they're women man like
it's just a natural thing to protect you
know what i'm saying i went out there
just running out of a knife going crazy
or something but
i don't know it's just natural to
protect and i just end up in a bad end
of it that's it
[Music]
why do you think that young men
particularly
although to some young women but mostly
young men why do they carry knives
because i think listen i can just give
you one message i've got a message the
other day in my phone i've got so much
messages
the guy said yeah i've been walking
around this night for three years here
hoping
to see the guy that killed my brother
and when i do i'm gonna use it in him
like you know i mean i've got other guys
saying that i have no money and my mom's
got no electric and she's disabled and
i'm caring for her you know what i'm
saying
it's heartbreaking like these kids are
in situations here where they can't even
escape if they want to the other guy
said
i'm going down to get milk for my mom
and i'll get them chased with mache they
know where his house is they know he's
shopped you know what i'm saying
like it's a proper tit-for-tat like some
tom and jerry business but it's serious
you know what i mean
so i just think that we need to just
um show a little more attention to these
children and skin and like just give
them a bit of
like warmth man and guidance you know
what i'm saying but that's what's going
to win right now so when you take a
knife off somebody or they they
voluntarily give you the knife
do they then not feel vulnerable given
what you've been saying no but obviously
these guys are saying that the guy
that's coming to me they're saying that
they want to transition from their life
and some people it's not only just
people are giving nice moms give me nice
i've had
my snipes with my mom i've had nice
older people that say that they want to
confiscate it and guess what
if you don't come to me and tell me that
you found a knife in a park because you
don't want to say that you
you had a knife i'm not going to judge
you and say oh mate just tell the truth
mate you got a knife for this yours
mate give me the knife that i know it's
not in your hand you can't put in
somebody else's and no one's gonna come
just and take it and it's gone
the reason i bring it to the police
station here is just to satisfy like
just like you know what i mean like
curiously you killed the cat
satisfaction brought it back i just want
everyone to know that i ain't got it
it's cool but right now
i'm about to start melting down these
nests i'm going to melt them down to
jewelry i'm going to make a big
i'm going to make a big big chain that
says faz amnesty on it yeah remember i
said that to you right here
and we'll like forget a t-shirt in it
i'm going to like i've done my research
it's forty thousand fourteen thousand
and fifty degrees here is the most
important for staying in this
my boy is doing research here i want to
start mowing that down you're going to
see me have a big family fast amnesty
chain like ching
saying nothing i promise you i said to
god
i'm just doing research i'm not that
smart and you could sell it on one of
these stores that you've been
stored exactly yeah my daughter's coming
to my store but she does here how is
your daughter
and she's 16. she's the one that was at
the party with the very first time i
want to confiscate enough but she's
really good there she tell me that story
so basically i went to a party no my
daughter went to my meniscus party
i'm going to do it quick here yeah on so
my daughter went to my niece's party she
was 40 minutes to 16.
went into the party one time yeah and
then my brother followed me and said bro
there's guys outside here with knives i
went down there i'm like what my
daughter's down there my niece is down
there i'm there so i was there brought
back back long story short
i've taught them at the party with a bit
of love it's not bullying this is this
is no i'm a bad man for you this is
little bro like come on like there's a
better life than this man you know i'm
saying that
and they gave me their knives and then
we just kept it moving you know what i'm
saying
and if anybody did um
question the authenticity of that yeah
then now you know yeah
that it like if i'm doing what i'm doing
now them little guys that is 14 and 15
in that party that knew me and my family
it was not hard to persuade them to hand
over their lives you know what i'm
saying
but it's love man i'm feeling bad it's
all good right now man
i feel like there's a nice positive
transition of these guys and
i believe that the um communication and
the trust
between us has like it's growing you
know i'm saying between me and the
community
and i also have to think it's growing
between me and local authorities as well
so tell me about the stalls tell me what
how that's going to work oh the store so
i've got one guy here he's
all right listen his name is joe leslie
yeah he's called courtney pride yeah
and he's come like he's got basically a
banging idea yeah
where children can like young people can
trade stuff
but as i'm saying to these guys here
they
there's loads of things you can sell
it's not only drugs if you find your
product
you can find your client you now find
your profit margin and that's what we've
done now so mate as i said my daughter's
in the coming store
we just ordered a bunch of stuff from
china for cheap mate come and sell
all the hair stuff in the store do you
know what i mean like and
my someone else is making dresses that
they make from scratch that's going to
go on a store like just little stuff
like that mate if you want to go buy
your little bluetooth
um little radios from china right for
two pound and come and sell them over
five pound each
and you make all that money the profit
for the month mate just pay your your
subscription fee for the month
bang bob's your uncle it's all yours
okay so
and and you can trade that online and
physically on the market stores
do you know what i mean so yeah so it's
consistent that you can do it you want
so do you think it is about
money and finances rather than about
protection in the long run
that's right when you say protection do
you mean protection from a local
authority or family
protecting yourself when you're carrying
a knife oh no um
so i think it's a bit of both like you
can never for anyone to try and pinpoint
is the one
situation thing it's that's silly like
that's like you're being oblivious to
facts
you know what i mean like you need to
understand yet there's there's there's
poverty
there's pride there's peer pressure
there's fear and it all amounts to one
thing you know what i'm saying so it's
not
no one can pinpoint what it is it's it's
just that
everybody needs to come together
everyone teaches
local authorities parents and even the
youngest brother like
life like life is important man like
life is very important
people are saying it's an epidemic at
the moment but you were stabbed what um
nearly 19 years ago something like that
um
so it's always been a problem i don't
know there's no way it
this as bad then as it is now
because now it's crazy like my things i
i believe like
it was hard to get into my position i
got into to get stabbed it wasn't just
because i was running around the roads
you know what i'm saying
like my both my stabbings um started in
a physical fight
with hands do you understand that the
stabbings both time came but after that
it went like we started stabbing each
other i never ever held a knife the
first time i got stabbed never had a
knife the second time i still never had
a knife
i knew i was angry for a long time i was
angry
like i was so angry and i wanted
everyone but in time yeah
and a bit of love and guidance from my
mommy brother i just
i just took that negative energy and
just
changed into a positive driving force
you know what i'm saying like
i'd walk past the guy and say hi and you
say hi to man like that's better than
that you know what i'm saying
that it's bigger than that life goes on
man hello again you are watching sky
news we have been
talking about knife crime at knifechime
campaigner farron alex ball
is uh with us hello again we're talking
about idris elba and what you thought
about him before we
ask your views uh let's hear what he has
to say
yeah knife crime is not new yeah i grew
up in the 80s and there was knife crying
back then
between blacks and whites and now it's
definitely between young black men in
small tiny communities and it's
affecting everyone we all look stupid
you look even more stupid if you've got
a knife or you know someone that's got a
knife
tell them to stab themselves right now
trust me because you're just going to
stab your future if you're going to stab
someone else
you become a murderer while you go to
prison for what
for some beef that lives within your
community you need to see past that
we have to say something about it as
well entertainers that are out there
there's young people that look up to us
man we need to just vocalize this
send a message out saying put the knives
down it's done
all right it's done we don't need to be
killing ourselves we have so much more
we can offer
and you're going to kill your future
you're going to kill someone else's
future
and it's dumb entertainers do me a favor
man put out similar videos
let's try and put out something and say
that we care for our communities
stop the knife crime please
i just say respect him like for him
in the position he's in like there's a
lot of people that just take the
backseat and
literally it's not there's no law that
says you have to get on your phone here
and put a video on social media to help
and he's done that so
all i can say is up more respect to him
man and like he's someone i look up at
the enemy soldier
somebody like that i i think it will
make a difference because
if there's people you look up to and you
see them saying you don't do that
then it helps you understand and it that
it just made
a younger person just think twice and
understand that
maybe farron's saying that i'll be
saying that giggs is saying that
this person you know what i'm saying
maybe this ain't the way forward so
yeah i mean if i could have such an
impact coming from where i've come from
mate like god knows what he where his
impact can go you know what i mean
so i'm just saying link up i just let's
do this man whoever's like-minded i want
to get this thing done let's go man
what do you think about stop and search
um i think stopping search is going to
be hard for the police to um achieve
because they
they're currently understaffed right
okay so if someone's currently
understaffed why are you going to give
them another workload
of stop and search what you need to do
on straight on is putting more of a
bigger police presence on the street
because no one's just going to run down
the road and start stabbing each other
from the police and that's it that's
what i've got to say about it because
that's a very political thing
and i want to know that when stopping
search come is everybody going to be
stopped and searched on a fair basis
not just certain people yeah they're
going to stereotype aren't they they're
going to
yeah there you go but i'm saying to you
straight up and down i believe the young
black males are going to be the
be the ones hit the most hard hard i'm
hard of this so
i mean i love my tracks metropolitan
police mate do not make a mistake when
you stop me but
i'm telling you but i wear my hoodie
every day and i wait for comfort you
know i'm saying i've got my hoodie on
right now
and this morning i love it 56 black men
straight shout out to you man see first
please i keep telling you you got 56
black men can i can you make number 57
please please what does that mean
because they've got something there
that's basically 56 blackberries 56
black men yeah and they're trying to
highlight
highlight how stereotypical is and how
black people get treated for these and
stuff like that
but the truth how do they get treated
because i think that they get treated
like
um they get they get picked on i believe
the police um
stereotyped them and i believe that as i
said to you like i'd be walking down the
road
and certain people they grab their bag
and they pull it to the side and step to
the side and it's got to the point where
now i will see someone down the road and
i know they're not like that so i go
down
i i move out of their physical space so
they don't do that movement that's going
to offend me you understand but i'm the
guy that'll probably help you out
i i will hold the door open all day for
you and take your bag then so now i'm
saying but
as i'm saying that people stop judging a
book by his cover man but you never know
what the story's going to read inside
but when you know we've seen all these
stabbings 39 stabbings to death so far
this year
a lot of them have involved young black
men
um you don't think even with that
uh evidence that a hundred percent yeah
because as i said but people say young
black men but if you go to scotland yeah
it's going to be
young black young caucasian men because
that's the population up there you're
talking about tottenham
and and you're talking about tottenham
what do you think you're going to see a
different nationality out there
of course it's going to be higher there
but the truth is i
would like say i have a hundred people
that's offered me knives just say
i'm telling you seventy percent of them
is being caucasian really and i don't
know whether that means the black people
are just holding their nice or they
don't want to give it to me
but i'm saying to you and it's not a
race thing here it's a
it's a community it's a social problem
do you understand so
so you're saying 70 out of 100 knives
that have been handed over
not been handed over about my messages
like tonight i'm saying but i
so out of the 30 i've probably picked up
like i can easily say that
20 of them like 20 plus has been from
caucasian people do you understand
and some of them's been through parents
something's been found in the park
so it's not one thing that you've got to
put your hand on it's a joint effort for
everyone
to show due diligence yeah and care in
the system for the children
what would you say to parents of i say
parents like
you have to respect parents you know but
not everyone's got the same life you
know some parents here i've got children
let's walk at the door and they can't
even hold them in the house
we're gonna do drag your kid in that
that's um 17 and six foot five
and then if you drag him by a shirt he
just calls social service and you get
bagged
listen parents yeah they're doing what
they can some of them and some of them
mean in it
but you can't put all parents on the one
brush you understand like
us sing single mom or single dad but
some some single parents
have raised the best of people in the
world do you understand and some don't
and some parents that's been in a fully
functioning and with
um a marriage for years they've got a
dysfunctional child
it's just what it is man that and people
adapt to the situations that's put in
front of them
to get over them if you know what i mean
you know what i'm saying
what are you going to do with your 10
kids how are you 10 you've got
listen yeah i'm proud of my kids in it
that as i'm saying genetically
impressive what it is now people keep
getting numbers wrong but right now i'm
not going to go into right now it's all
love i'm a father and i love my children
yeah and i'll keep loving them
and they're one of the biggest driving
forces what advice do you give to them
how do you keep them on the straight and
narrow
all my kids are doing a levels in gcses
none of my kids have got no problem with
the police
i'm fine that's it like the guidance is
there they know right from wrong and
that's it right like don't make rocket
science of it
it's that the kids are better what what
do you how do you
create what i do i make sure that's the
other thing
well i make sure that my children i try
to give them
what i can so they don't look for
anywhere else
when they go to school and stuff and
they got good reports their mum would
contact me and stuff like that and i
make sure that
i make a big fuss about it wow that's
excellent though like listen we're going
to shop to buy you some trainers like
because
now now that would encourage positive
repetit repetitive behavior do you
understand
so it's not dying it's just like mate
listen if you tell your dog to sit
a puppy that's it rob it's going to get
a reward thank you so brother listen
treat your kids man that
it's just loving it like it ain't got to
be financial it's got to be like even a
little cuddle even a little that's
good well done son they go a long ways
like my seven-year-old son here
he still says i love you dad when i say
simpson i love you he's like i love you
that
and that to me is just so amazing that
well it means so much to me that i'm
saying
but well it's all loving it yeah
so how are we going to roll out what
you're doing so basically
what needs to happen is now hopefully
the local authorities that can
basically add some legality to my what
i'm doing
they i'm happy to work with them and
conduct them and i don't know maybe we
can replicate this in a bigger scale
maybe we can get some local authorities
involved i'm willing and
anyone that's like-minded for the same
agenda of stopping the killing
and preserving youth then let's go do
you think it's
we've we've reached a position now where
we are becoming more aware that we do
need to go out and help our kids and
actually the epidemic that we're talking
about is is gonna start subscribing well
i don't know
because who else is actually going out
there and doing it no one is really i'd
like
but people like you and yeah we're
holding a torch yeah we're holding the
torch but that's what i'm saying that
i've like
we're holding the torch above you but
i've hit the road with my torch and i'm
looking in the alleyway to see what i
can see you get me
but other people need to come true and
hit and start hitting the roadside as
well
because it's a presence you understand
when people like you know if someone
knew you cared for them
then maybe they wouldn't be so
dysfunctional and so careless
because someone cares for you you know
it's all about love yeah um
what would you say to some people who
are potentially watching this afternoon
who've got a knife that are thinking
about
going out i'm just saying this like it's
not rocket science a life is not worth
your knife
i mean a knife is not worth your life
bro it's that simple in it
what about if you're going out to take
your knife for protection
no that's wrong just like that because
you're going to get stabbed or you can
go enjoy yourself in it all i'm saying
here
nobody cares until these days and
everybody's gonna wait till it's too
late
don't do it man like trust me that let's
jump in this thing and help the youths
man
they're our future like nike god forbid
i'm just saying like
you know christian ronaldo where would
you be without such a man right now
imagine he would love to something so
senseless you know what i'm saying
like i'm saying like all these people
just start sponsoring our future
athletes like if you see someone in the
school that's running sub 10
nike get down there and make him love
himself let one of the athletes sign his
trainers but you know what i do for him
when i'm doing afflicts yeah
i was wearing my coaches ex-students
boots from 11 years ago and i was still
winning you know someone who come to me
and gave me the pair of fresh boots
that probably inspired me to keep doing
it you know what i'm saying like bro
just show something about this love man
that's what it is man not even love his
guidance it's just but i'm like you know
a flower yeah without water and sunlight
it's not gonna grow
it's that simple if i nurture it it will
grow and when it blossoms and realize
how pretty and beautiful it is it won't
want to lose it
amazing ah you're amazing how are you
it's lovely to talk to you sadly we're
out of time i could have talked to you
all afternoon
great to see you how amazing is he
we'll be back in just a second